Last week we talked about--
we went quantum.
We had Dr. Quantum
show us the way.
And this week, we're going to
go quantum for electrons, right?
That's what we're
going to do this week.
These are my two favorite
quantum mechanicists
of all time.
I believe that
this sign is meant
to teach us something about
the double slit experiment.
And just as you're
leaving the lot,
knowing that there
is some chance
that your one car could
actually split into two,
go through both
exits, and recombine.
Just like an electron
does through two slits.
And in fact, we know
that that's possible now.
And if we wanted to, you could
write down-- from de Broglie--
you could write down like the
wavelength of a car, right?
So like in a car--
I don't know, your
lambda of the car
would be equal to h over mv.
And if you plus some
numbers in, this
is going to be something
like oh, you know,
maybe 10 to the
minus 37th meters.
It's small, but it's a wave.
Your car is a wave, you know?
The baseball is a wave.
The electron-- we are all waves.
And I know, and that's what--
so the electron is a wave.
And I know-- hashtag,
we are all waves.
Because it's a thing.
It's really a thing.
Because it's true.
I am a wave.
You are a wave.
We are all waves.
It's just-- our wavelengths
are pretty small,
but they're not zero.
And so the next time
you get-- oh, we're
on the same wavelength.
You really are.
It's true.
We are-- right?
That's deep.
We are waves.
All of us.
And so, the wavelength--
OK, the wavelength for an
electron was something like 10
to the minus 10th meters.
Which made it a really nice
way to interrogate images.
And that was my "why this
matters" last week, right?
On Friday.
So you can take advantage of
that wavelength to do things.
Like see electron
microscopy, right?
But everyone's awake.
That's what quantum
mechanics told us.
But what we want
to do now is know
how to represent this wave.
So everything's waving.
We've got that.
But how do I describe it?
Right?
And that's where we left off.
And we left off
by me telling you
that it all led to Schrodinger,
who came up with the wave
equation for quantum mechanics.
And the wave equation
of Schrodinger
is really pretty
incredible, because--
so I'm not going to
write out Schrodinger.
That would take me forever.
So I'm going to
write S. Eq., right?
The Schrodinger equation, right?
And here-- so what he had is he
had the sort of wave behavior
that was captured.
And it was captured
automatically.
And it gave us also
allowed energies, you see?
So, allowed energies.
And this is also
the quantization.
Ah-- I ran out of room.
Right.
But now, If you go
back to classical--
so if you think about
classical physics, what
you would have is something
like maybe F equals ma.
But what that gives you--
well, it doesn't give
you wave behavior,
but it gives you
continuous energies.
Continuous energies.
So the powerful point here
is that from that equation--
and we don't need to
know this equation.
We're not going to derive it.
Right?
Today I'm going to tell
you how it's solved,
but you don't need to
know how to solve it.
But you need to know
what the solutions mean.
That's what we're
talking about today.
But that equation-- what it
does is it sets up the energies
as a function of the wave.
Psi-- that function, psi--
is the wave function, OK?
And so you get waves by default,
because that's what you're
solving for-- these waves.
And then you have
a minus second--
oh, there's an h bar.
That's an h over 2 pi.
Right?
But it's like the same
Planck's constant.
OK.
But the wave
behavior gives you--
because there's only
certain energies that
solve that equation.
So quantization
falls out naturally.
You don't have to
put it in anymore.
It is a direct result of
solving this equation.
If I take a wave--
think about this, right.
If you take a wave and
you put it in a box,
then it can only have
certain solutions.
Once you define the box,
if you throw a wave in it,
well, that's where those
things are on the right are.
Maybe it's a standing wave.
And so it's going to look--
no-- it's going to be like this.
One solution.
And some energy.
Or maybe it's going to look--
I didn't leave myself any room--
like this.
And it's going to have
some other energy, right?
1, 2.
That's it.
If you throw a wave
in a box-- like,
here's the first
one, second one.
But there are only certain
ones that are going to work.
All right, and you
can get that sense.
Because otherwise it's not
going to line up and then
be able to wave and keep going.
It's not going to
be a standing wave.
Right?
So you get this sense
right away of quantization.
Only certain waves, and
only certain energies,
will solve this equation.
Now, here's the key, is this--
we're going to throw an electron
into this equation, right?
But we're going to throw it
into the right potential.
And that is the potential that
we know it sits in, in an atom.
Which is simply a
Coulomb potential.
So this is how we
get there, right?
We take Schrodinger's
equation of quantum mechanics.
And we solve it for an
electron waving in the presence
of the potential of the atom.
Which is a positive potential.
And you can see, this is a--
OK, V is a potential.
And that's an attractive
potential, right?
That's an attractive potential.
So what happens when we do that?
So that's what
we're going to do.
I'm going to leave this for--
so.
What happens?
So if we take a hydrogen atom--
or as I've written it here, a
"Hatom," then you would have--
Let's see.
What do you get from this?
Well, you get that the potential
is going to be minus 1 over r.
Yeah.
It goes as minus 1--
an e and an over-permittivity
of space and stuff like that.
But it goes as minus 1 over r.
That's the Coulomb potential.
Right?
A plus charge is sitting
outside of a minus charge.
Ah!
That was a close call.
The electron is sitting out
here, and there's the nucleus.
And the potential feels
is a Coulomb potential.
OK, so that's point 1.
Point 2 is that we're
going to apply the--
oh, I'm saving
myself so much time.
I love it, when you're
efficient like that--
S. Eq.
Schrodinger equation.
The Schrodinger equation.
But the way that we're going
to do this is in spherical
coordinates.
Spherical coords.
And all that means
is that I'm going
to write psi as a function
of r, theta, and phi.
And the last thing
that I'm going to do
is I'm going to
separate the variables.
And that's just a
standard way to solve
mathematical equations.
So I'm going to
separate the variables.
So separate.
And so what that means is
that psi can be written as one
function-- let's call it r--
of the radius, times another
function, p, of the theta,
times another function f of phi.
So that's my separation
of variables, OK?
Again, I'm not all
about having you know
how to solve this equation.
OK?
That you can learn
in quantum mechanics.
But what I'm all about is what
that quantum mechanics solution
means for us here in chemistry.
And this is deep.
This is deep, because--
why?
Because this whole thing
is quantized, right?
So just like before, there's
only certain allowed values
for the wave function.
There's only certain allowed
values for these variables.
Each one of them is quantized.
Each one of them.
OK?
And that's what we need
to learn about today,
is what that means
for chemistry.
All right.
So now we're going to go
through the quantum numbers
and see what they mean.
And we're going to start
with this first one,
the radial function.
So radial, and then
two angular functions.
OK.
Now the radial--
so what do we get?
Well, the radial function--
I'm using a word here,
I got to tell you why.
Orbital of hydrogen, right?
So I've solved this now.
I've solved this equation,
and I'm plotting this orbital
for first quantization--
n equals 1, n equals 2,
n equals 3.
We've got to talk
about this, right?
But I'm just plotting what
that function looks like.
Well, let's compare.
Because if I'm Bohr,
then what I have is this.
Remember this?
I've got like this--
OK, there's 1, and
it's going around,
and it's very happy in an orbit.
But see, we don't call
these orbits anymore.
And it's going to be clear as
we talk about this picture,
because these aren't
distinct orbits, right?
So now in quantum
what you have--
I'm just going to take
that n equals 1 solution.
That's the first solution
to the radial part, right?
That's not a fixed distance.
That's not a fixed
distance, right?
So now I'm just looking
at the radial distribution
of the probability.
The probability of
finding the electron.
That's how we speak
when we speak quantum.
We don't say it's here, right?
We say it could be here.
I don't know.
But there's a probability
that it's there.
So now it sort of has
a probability cloud.
Now it looks like it
gets a little less--
why am I drawing spirals?
It looks like it gets
a little less probable
as you go further out, right?
So maybe the density of
probability-- because look,
right?
It's got a peak there.
But even if I just plot
that first orbital,
even as I go all the way out
to here, it is non-0, right?
So this is probability.
And this would be n equals 1.
So it's a totally
different story.
That electron isn't in
one place, but it is.
But it's not.
It could be anywhere.
It could be-- if
I'm a hydrogen atom,
my electron could literally
be across the room.
There is a finite
probability that that's true.
And we know that since
we are all waves,
and we can all be defined
by the equations of quantum
mechanics-- and in fact, that
is the way to define the world--
that we also have probabilities.
They're small, you know.
But I could be over
there right now.
There's a chance.
My weight function
is not exactly 0
all the way over there.
It's close.
But it's not exact, right?
That is a very different picture
of an electron in an orbit--
in fact, it's not an orbit.
It's an orbital.
And that's where we say orbital.
That's why we stay it.
OK, but-- we're listing
quantum numbers.
These are the quantum numbers.
Oh, oh- I'm going all caps.
Didn't even know I
was going to do that.
So we have n, which is
called the principle--
principle quantum number.
And this is going to be related
to the main energy, kind
of e, 1, 1, right?
E, 2, 2.
So this is going to be related
to the main energy level.
Main energy level, right?
And it's also related
to the radial distance.
Radial distance.
And sometimes we
call this the shell.
So sometimes the
principal quantum number,
this is the shell, right?
It's the first shell,
or the second shell.
So we can call this the shell.
Come back to that later.
And you can see right there.
OK, we'll talk about n
equals 2 and 3 in a second.
But you know-- oh,
let's talk about it now.
You can see right there--
it I go from n equals 1 to n
equals 2, then I'm further out.
Yeah, I still got non-0.
Doesn't quite go to 0
like I just said there.
But it's further out,
it's shifted out, right?
So with increasing n--
so another thing
we can say about n
is that with increasing n, you
get higher energies and larger
distances.
larger r, a [? hole. ?]
But you get something else.
You get something else,
and you can see it there.
And I've been avoiding it, but
I got to address it right now.
Because those higher
end functions go to 0.
So they have nodes.
With increasing n,
you get more nodes.
What's a node?
A node is when it goes to 0.
And there's more of them.
Now that's also
really important.
So what that means is in
Bohr, my orbit was r, e.
Heisenberg said no way.
Can't have them both.
But I had a r,
which was one value.
And remember-- it
could only then
be the r of the next
value, the next n.
Now I'm basically
saying the opposite.
I'm saying, well actually,
r can be anything.
There's a probability
cloud, so this electron
could be anywhere with certain
probability, except not here.
In this one place.
This node.
It's 0.
It's literally 0.
The probability of finding
the electron there is 0.
It cannot exist there.
But how bizarre is that?
The electron can exist
with probability out here,
and probability in here, but
it can't exist in between.
It's the same electron.
Try explaining how it
goes back and forth.
It skips over a zero
probability part, r.
Right?
But these nodes
are very important.
And just to give you a
sense of what this means,
I found a very fancy
animation, because I
want to make sure
you guys understand.
So here's the electron.
It's doing this, it's
doing its waving thing.
But look at what
happens with the nodes.
Uh uh.
The probability
there is always 0.
You see that?
Can't go-- no.
Not gonna exist there.
Right?
That is super deep.
Because there's no classical
analog to these things.
There's no classical analog.
But this is what
electrons do in an atom.
Now, this is what the
clouds look like--
a little better
drawn than mine--
for n equals 1, n equals
2, and n equals 3.
So again, you can see--
this is one electron.
It's colored differently,
just to contrast it,
but this is one electron.
Right?
And
These are plus and
minus of this, right?
So it'd be like a wavy
wave, and you're just
showing plus and minus
with the yellow and blue.
But that note in between
is where it can never be.
But it's one electron.
It's not many, it's one.
And this is its
probability distribution.
Now I want to make one
really important point, which
is that--
look at what I'm plotting here.
Maybe something-- that's
size squared, right?
So it's only the square
of the wave function
that we can relate any
physical meaning to.
The physical meaning
I just related to you
is the probability
of being somewhere.
That's what size squared
gives us-- the probability
of being somewhere.
But ask your teacher--
not me, your quantum teacher.
Ask what psi means.
And they're going to have a--
it's going to be an
interesting class.
Force the issue.
Don't let them go
until they answer.
We still don't know.
We still don't know
what the actual wave
function means physically.
We cannot attribute a
physical meaning to it,
only to its square.
So we go about our business
for the last 100 years
squaring it and saying, OK,
well it describes nature.
That's great.
But no one, still, knows what
it means without the square.
I find that incredible.
And it led Bohr to say all
sorts of really cool things.
He said, "We must be clear
that when it comes to atoms,
language can be used
only as in poetry.
The poet, too, is not
nearly so concerned
with describing facts
as with creating images
and establishing
mental connections."
That's Bohr like
deep in it, trying
to figure out what psi means.
He's like, I don't know.
It's poetry.
OK, that's cool.
That's cool.
V squared means
something, v doesn't.
Really?
No.
Classically, we've got nothing.
Right?
Quantum mechanics.
Oh, it's a beautiful thing.
Why does this matter?
I'm going to give you a
brief "why this matters."
And we've been talking about
the quantum nature of things,
right?
Quantum is this.
Quantum are these differences.
It's this probability.
It's quantization of energies.
What does that mean, right?
Well, last time I told
you that by electrons
being quantum, and having
wave-like character--
we're able to use
them to see things,
and it started the
nanotechnology revolution
about 30 years ago.
And today I want to give
you an example of that
in my "why this matters."
And it has to do with quantum
domination, which should be
the title of a movie or a book.
And here's the example-- take
a piece of bulk material.
Take a piece of silicon, OK?
And if you look at
the silicon, it's
kind of boring to
look at optically.
It's not very interesting.
You know, don't tell
that to your iPhone,
which has a lot of it in
there, but it's boring.
But now, take out your little
nano ice cream scooper,
which you all have.
And you take a little
tiny piece of it.
We call that a quantum dot.
Why?
We call it a quantum dot
because it kind of looks
like a dot-- its smallish.
But we call it that
because quantum mechanics
takes over the properties.
Here's an example-- shine
light on this thing,
or have it glow, and
all of a sudden instead
of being boring it can
be any color you want.
Why?
Because if I shine
light-- and here is
a very sophisticated picture
of a laser, which you can tell
I had trouble
making transparent.
And so you shine a
laser on this piece--
we know already, light
excites charge in an atom.
It does the same in solids.
So here's my piece of
silicon, and what that does
is it sends an electron
up in energy levels.
But the electron is
up in an energy level,
and it left behind a hole.
Which is something we'll
talk about later when
we talk about semiconductors.
A hole is just a
positive charge.
And it turns out that that
electron and that hole
are attracted to each other, but
not-- they can't get too close.
But they want to kind of hang
out at a certain distance.
Where?
How far?
Yeah-- quantum mechanics.
N 2, 3, 4 tells us.
It tells us how far, right?
They want to hang out--
and now all of a sudden,
I've nano-scooped them out,
and I've made a quantum dot.
But if I try to do
the same thing there,
that's how far
they wanted to be.
And they can't be.
They literally ran
out of real estate.
They ran out of atoms.
They cannot be out here, because
there's no stuff out here.
So they get squeezed.
I am squeezing these
quantum mechanical objects,
this electron and this hole.
And by squeezing them,
I'm changing the way
they interact with light.
I'm changing the color, right?
Oh.
It's all stuff we've
learned that explains
something revolutionary.
By the way, if you buy a QLED
TV, is it as good as OLED?
No.
But is it better than LED?
Yeah, a little bit.
That's what they-- QLED--
quantum is quantum dots.
They have coated the LED
emitters with quantum dots
to give you better color.
Now what this means,
why this matters,
is nothing less than the
periodic table itself.
Because I think I
showed you this--
we're living in these
different ages, which I love.
We have the periodic
table that has--
the ability to work with
it is what's brought us
to the age of materials design.
But see, now I've literally
just told you that by changing
the size-- nothing
more than the size--
I can tune a property
because of quantum mechanics.
Because I'm changing its
quantum mechanical interactions.
It would be like saying, I can
take a piece of this table--
I can break a piece
of this table,
and it's now going to be red.
That's exactly what we're
doing, but at a very tiny size.
That is as if we are
taking this periodic table
and giving it a whole
other dimension.
Every element can do more
things than we thought possible
because we can tune
these properties related
to quantum mechanics.
So that's a big deal.
That's a very big deal.
OK.
Now back to our solution to
the Schrodinger equation.
For an electron in an atom.
Because now we move on and
we solve for the next one,
which is--
OK, so we did r.
Now we're going to do theta.
And what happens
with theta is, you
get another quantization
of that variable.
And that's the second
quantum number.
So we're going to put it here.
N-- I'll number them
so we don't lose track.
Who knows how many they'll be?
OK.
Not three.
OK, so the second one is l.
And it's the angular
quantum number.
And it has also
quantization 0, 1, 2, 3.
OK?
So l can be--
Oh, I need to put that up there.
I meant to put that right here.
This is just like what we
learned for Bohr, right?
And l can be 0, 1, 2, all
the way up to l minus 1.
OK?
I'm going too fast,
that's n minus 1.
L goes from 0 to n minus 1.
OK, so what that
means right away--
what you can see-- if it
only goes to n minus 1,
then for example for n
equals 1 then l equals 0.
That's it.
There's no other options.
It stops, right?
And we have a name for this.
We call this s, the s orbital.
And for n equals 2, l
can be 0, or l can be 1.
And this one is called--
this one is the p orbital.
This is the p orbital, OK?
Those have names.
And so on and so on.
d, f--
This is old notation that
we cannot get rid of.
This is called
spectroscopic notation,
because it comes
from spectroscopists.
And remember, I told you-- never
make a spectroscopist angry.
Don't do it.
And so we use their
notation still.
s was sharp.
Spherically symmetric.
p was principle,
because it sort of
dominated in some experiments.
d was more diffuse.
f fundamental, because it looked
kind of like the hydrogen atom
sometimes.
These shouldn't be the names,
but they are because they still
stay with us.
Spectroscopic
notation-- s, p, d, f.
What they really do
is just correspond--
that looks like "porbital."
Let's put a little
more space there.
P orbital.
Right?
Because what they really
mean is nothing more
than a quantum number for the
second quantum number, which
is the angular quantum number.
These are also sometimes
called subshells, right?
Because they're
underneath the shell.
And as you can see
from this picture,
it describes the angular shape.
The angular shape
of the orbital.
The shape, right?
So it gives us a shape.
Now-- if we think about it, and
we think about that p orbital,
that has a different shape
than the [INAUDIBLE]..
Then you think, well,
this could be aligned
in different directions, right?
So if I think about
that p orbital-- well,
I could align it in
three different ways.
It could go along this axis,
this axis, or that one, right?
And so those are p
orbitals in hydrogen
that have three
possible orientations,
and that automatically gets
us to another quantum number.
In fact, it's the last
one, and it makes sense
just physically--
that's phi, right?
So the last one--
or is it the last one--
is m.
And we call it m sub l, which
is the magnetic quantum number.
And this one can have
quantization equal to minus l,
right?
All the way up to plus l.
So the number of orientations
that the orbital can have--
if I'm a-- n equals
2, l equals 1,
then m sub l equals
minus 1, 0, 1.
Three orientations.
Right?
It's got three orientations--
three possible magnetic quantum
numbers.
Why is it called the
magnetic quantum number?
Because those are
the experiments.
We're done using magnetization--
magnetic fields--
to discover these
orientations, to
sort through it.
To see it.
OK.
So if I had l equals--
all right, so if I had,
for example l equals 2.
Then m sub l would
have five values.
Five possible values, right?
I should put a plus
there, just to be sure we
keep track of minus and plus.
These are quantum numbers.
That means they're
integers, right?
But they can have these ranges
and these rules, and again--
you may think, why did
this come out like this?
Well, it comes out from
solving this equation--
separation of variables--
with that potential.
That's it, right?
That's it.
You get these allowed values of
these three variables, quantum
numbers.
OK?
All right.
Now-- and there's the d.
These are called d--
So if n equals 2--
OK.
So did I mess up here?
No, I didn't, because n would
have to be 3 here, right?
For l to be 2.
Because l can't be equal to
n, because I wrote it there
as the list of allowed quantum
numbers that l can have.
And there it is
for the d orbitals.
And so there's five d orbitals.
Five d orbitals.
And you can do f on your own,
and it's an extremely fun thing
to do at night.
Late at night.
Now, this gives
you the orbitals.
You get them all.
These are the orbitals.
These are the beautiful,
beautiful orbitals
that we have from
quantum mechanics
describing an
electron in an atom.
Which tells you everything about
where that electron can be,
how it behaves, what
its energies are,
and therefore literally why
atoms are what they are.
That's what it tells us, right?
Because the next thing we need
to do is fill up our atoms.
And know how electrons fill
atoms using these quantum
numbers.
And then relate
that to chemistry,
and to the differences
between one atom and another,
and explaining why
atoms are different.
Remember, that was our goal.
We needed to go
quantum to answer that.
So we're getting closer,
but we're still not there.
And one of the reasons is there
is a fourth quantum number.
And this came out
of experiments--
I thought that I
would just show you
a very quick video, because it's
easier to see this in action.
And so these are
experiments that
were done by Stern
and Gerlach that
showed something very
peculiar about atoms
and their electrons.
OK, so here I'm just
going to play it.
It's got a really nice--
oh, that's loud.
Yeah?
I don't mind that.
That's good.
So you can read the text here.
OK, so they've got a magnet.
A very strong magnet, right?
Magnetic fields.
And they're going to
shoot a classical magnet.
There's a classical magnet.
And you see it's going to
react to the magnetic field,
and be pushed up.
That magnetic could've
been oriented differently.
Like sideways, right?
In which case it
doesn't feel this.
And you could throw
a bunch of them
randomly, with
random orientations,
and that's what you would see.
[JAZZY MUSIC]
It's good music, too.
But now-- watch this.
I love the animation here.
Look at this.
And the bass, right?
Those are what happens
to atoms with electrons.
You'd shoot them
through a high field,
and you don't get anything.
You get two things.
Only two.
[JAZZY MUSIC]
I'm just playing it because
I really want to groove out
and I'm debating--
OK.
All done.
I was debating how
embarrassing it would be
if I just started grooving out.
So this was Sterin and Gerlach,
who discovered, essentially,
a fourth quantum number that
can have only two values.
So they showed that this thing
that the atoms were doing
was because of the electrons.
And that the only
way you could explain
what these electrons
were doing is if there
was this thing called spin.
And if you really need
to think classically--
and it's dangerous to do
so, because then you'd
forget that I could be all
the way over there, right?
Right now.
But if you really need
to think classically,
you can think of
a charge spinning.
It could be spinning
this way or that way.
In a way, it helps
our classical needs.
But it's so not
what's happening.
But it does help our
classical desires, right?
And that would give
you the two fields.
Right?
But I would advise you just
to think about spin as simply
a fourth quantum number.
And so we call
that one number 4.
Not from that equation.
Separate from those experiments.
And that is-- we call
that the spin M sub
s is the spin quantum number.
And it's the fourth
one in our series.
The fourth quantum number.
And it has only two values--
up or down.
Or if you like, you could write
it as plus 1/2 or minus 1/2.
Or you could write it
as up or down arrows.
So many ways to distinguish
two things that are opposite.
Spin up, spin down.
Two values that this can have.
So we're not ready yet.
We're still not ready.
We're so close, but we're
still not there, right?
Because we still don't
know, well-- can't I just--?
How do I--?
What are the rules
here going to be?
For populating atoms.
And this is where Pauli said
something very important,
and made this incredibly
important statement.
Which is that-- no particles
in the same system--
read that as, no electrons
in the same atom--
can have the same
quantum numbers.
No electrons in the same atom
can have the same quantum
numbers.
And that immediately tells you--
again, this has to do with the
nature of quantum mechanics--
what that immediately tells
you is that two electrons--
ho-ho, this is big!
Two electrons-- I'm gonna write,
two electrons, and watch this--
I'm going all caps--
only two electrons
can occupy an orbital.
An orbital.
Or- bi- tal.
That called the Pauli
exclusion principle.
OK.
So we're going to use
all of this information
to fill stuff up, but I
don't want to do that yet.
On Wednesday, we're
filling up the table,
and we're making
our first solid.
I figure it's our
three week anniversary.
I know you've all been
looking forward to it.
I've been thinking
about it a lot.
And I think-- that makes
me want to throw t-shirts.
[STUDENTS CHEERING]
I got to do this.
All right, all right.
I got to go--
I know.
I got to go backwards here.
OK, OK, hold on, hold on.
I'm missing there
and there, I know.
I got to work on my arm.
Yeah.
Show you love over there.
OK, all right.
I'll have more on Wednesday,
and the reason is--
we're making our first solid.
I almost wanted to
leave it a surprise,
but I couldn't help myself.
It's extremely exciting.
This is, after all,
solid-state chemistry,
and Wednesday we're
making a solid.
Literally.
We are not only making a bond,
but we're making a solid,
and talking about solids.
So that's going to
be very exciting.
And we're going to start
by filling elements.
But before we do that, I
want to explain something
very important, which is--
what's happening with energy?
Right?
We did just see
something dramatic.
As you go from Bohr to quantum,
something very dramatic
happens with where, right?
And we know something
else very dramatic
happens, which is right here.
You know, that's Bohr over
there- n equals 1, [INAUDIBLE]..
Bohr is 1, 2, 3, right?
Now it's like-- oh no,
wait, it's 1 and with 1s.
2-- I can put two electrons
in there, thanks to Pauli.
I know I can put two, because
I have all the quantum
numbers in here the
same except spin, which
could be up or down, right?
N equals 1, l equals 0, m sub
l equals 0, spin is up or down.
Two electrons.
But look, I'm now
here at n equals 2,
going from the Bohr
model to quantum.
I've got this and I've
got three p orbitals.
So now all of a sudden
I've got eight electrons
that can go into
that quantum number.
That's very different
than Bohr, right?
And that's called degeneracy,
because you're taking something
and you're saying, there
are multiple variations
that have the same n.
But there's
something else that I
want to explain right now
that is can be understood very
physically and intuitively.
And that is that
the motivation-- one
of the big motivations
of this was that we
needed more than one electron.
Our atoms are not all
hydrogen and ionized atoms.
They are just neutral atoms
going up above hydrogen.
So what happens when
we go multi electron?
And there's two effects
that I want to explain.
Here's what happens
to this picture.
Those are the one
electron levels, right?
There's Bohr over there.
This is what you really
get in terms of energy.
Right?
This is energy along
the vertical axis.
And there's two reasons,
two very important reasons,
why these are so different.
One is called
shielding, and the other
is called orbital penetration.
And I want to talk
about both of them
in the last seven
minutes of class.
I'm going over here.
All right, so let's talk about--
let's do shielding first.
Shielding is something
that you can kind of
get a very good sense for it
if you just look at what's
happening in these atoms.
So in shielding--
let's take an example.
I'm going to give you an
atom with 15 protons and 15
electrons.
What atom is it?
Anybody know?
Phosphorus.
OK, so I'm going to take an
example of the phosphorus atom,
OK?
And I've got 15 positive
charges in the nucleus.
15.
Right?
Now, 15 protons.
Now I've got my
levels, and it gets
very difficult to draw levels
as probability distributions.
So I'm going to draw them
as rings, even though we
know they're not, right?
These are my orbitals.
But I've got like an electron
here, OK, an electron there.
All right.
So I've got two electrons
in the n equals 1--
n equals 1 orbital.
So that's the 1s orbital,
right there on the bottom.
But if I go out--
OK, so I'm going to go out now.
To n equals 2.
Well, now I've got
1, 2, 3, 4, and--
oh boy-- put one here.
5, 6, 7, 8.
Because here-- remember, I've
got l equals 0 and l equals 1,
and as we just said, because
n sub s can be up or down,
I've got eight electrons here.
So here, I've got n equals
1, here I've got n equals 2.
That's eight electrons.
And then out here--
oh, now it gets really
interesting-- because for n
equals 3, how many
electrons do I have left?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And you can already
see what's happening.
So remember, Rutherford
told us this.
All this charge is in a
tiny little point here.
You wouldn't even see it if
we were drawing this to scale.
But what are these
electrons seeing?
What are the electrons seeing?
Well, these inner two
electrons are just
seeing this huge
amount of charge.
They are happy.
Low energy.
Right?
The lower your
energy, the happier.
You're in a lower
energy, ground state.
Remember-- more lower
energy, more happiness.
More bound.
Right?
So those electrons down
there are enjoying.
But these out here--
you see?
These electrons.
Those electrons in here--
these shield the outer
electrons, these shield
outer electrons
by two electrons.
Right?
Because they're
kind of in the way.
It's like you've got this
negative charge that's
in between me and the
positive charge, right?
And so if I'm out
here at n equals 2,
I don't see 15 positive
charges there anymore.
I see 13-- ish.
That's shielding.
But now this one--
this has the 2s and
the 2p electrons.
It's got eight electrons
there, and those
are shielding another eight.
Those are shielding
another eight protons.
To things outside
of them, right?
Shielding doesn't work going in.
If I'm this electron and I look
out, all I see are repulsive--
I see repulsiveness.
In a good way--
I'm sure they're friends.
But two negative charges, right?
So I'm only looking in.
Looking in, shielded.
So these ones have
sort of an effective--
z effective.
You know, that could
be something like five.
This is not the z of
the atom, but it's
sort of like those very
outer electrons don't
see the whole proton cloud.
They get shielded.
And that's a very
important part of what
happens to orbitals when you
put a lot of electrons in them.
And there's one more
thing that happens,
and it goes back to this plot
that I showed you before,
which is that the
orbitals themselves
are very different than just
like a straight line from Bohr.
They have these
shapes to them, right?
So the second thing that happens
is that if I have that same s--
this is s, so this
would now be the 1s.
And now I'm going to put--
remember that 2s
looked like this.
And it had the node there.
Remember that?
Ho-ho.
That was 2s.
But now we're going
to put the 2p there.
May not be drawn to scale.
OK, here's the 2p.
Something very, very
interesting is happening here.
And again, it has to do with
what electrons are seeing.
Because the 2s electron
has a probability--
remember, this is the
probability normalized,
so we put in r-squared
there, right?
That probability-- all that
means is if I integrate over
everything, it's 1.
It's got to be somewhere.
But look, the 2s electron can be
really deep inside the shells.
It can be in there.
Literally-- look, it's
even inside the 1s.
So it gets some of that
15-proton action, right?
Orbital penetration
leads to massive changes.
Orbital penetration is
what this is called,
and it allows some of the--
but the p doesn't have that.
It goes in a little,
but the p doesn't
have that peak, all
the way in there,
where it can see all
that positive charge.
And that is why these
two things are different.
You see?
Because the 2s now,
can be closer sometimes
to those 15 protons, right?
And so it lowers the
energy, making it happier.
It finds a lower happy place.
OK?
So we're going to use this,
and on Wednesday, we're
going to take these things and
we're going to fill them up,
and we're going to
make our first solid.
Have a very good
rest of your day.